so about four years ago
I decided to take a month off sabbatical
terrifying I went to Australia for an
entire month
and yeah it was terrifying I mean it was
great too I was in Australia what's not
to love uh but
to not open the laptop to not
edit the blog post to not engage in any
of that
was perhaps the most uncomfortable I'd
ever been
and it's not a switch that can just get
switched off and it's not something that
um
gets easier even a week later like you
really do need a lot of time like I
needed that entire month like it wasn't
even actually until the last week where
I started to feel
a little bit more grounded what did you
do
uh I kept it really simple I mean I have
friends I was in Sydney that year I've
gone I've gone to Australia twice so
I've done this every year
I've gone to Hawaii twice and all those
places I have lots of friends lots of
opportunity to do fun stuff and see lots
of people and blah blah blah but I
really treat it like
a retreat and so I live
those days quite monastically I do what
I enjoy I'm in a tropical location I get
up I make my morning smoothie and then I
go out and I train I ride my bike for
four hours I go to the ocean and swim
um I I push myself physically and then I
come back I eat I would I go to the
beach I read watch a movie go to bed at
eight o'clock and and try actually not
to talk to anybody and to not be online
um
if there's any output at all it's just
in journaling with intention
and those pages ultimately creating the
foundation for an idea or something
later but besides that no work
what have you
learned
about your direction or your goals or
yourself through these manuaries
one a very
tactical level I've learned to trust my
team and that I can let go so that in
and of itself
that you can take a step back and the
whole
Castle doesn't cave in on itself and the
world continues to spin and the work
gets done is incredibly
comforting and empowering
um
because it taught me that I can step
away and it's not going to be a disaster
uh
I don't think that you
can have the level of clarity on who you
are and what you're doing when
you're in the machinations
of the creative process there's a myopia
like you're what you're doing six
interviews in four days or something
like that and then I mean you're on a
hustle grind right when you're on the
hustle and you're on the grind there's a
sort of euphoric feeling that comes with
that and a sense of Pride and and
accomplishment that are that's all good
but you're not seeing the forest for the
trees because you're staring at the
leaves on one particular tree uh and so
in order to have that perspective you
have to stop
and if you don't you're robbing yourself
of the greater opportunity that's right
in front of you because you've created
your own
treadmill for yourself
and it becomes very easy especially if
you're getting success to just keep
doing that thing
but sometimes you have to pattern
interrupt in order to identify
the greater opportunity or
the orthogonal
opportunity that you can't see when
you're in the midst of the grind there's
a
cognitive bias I guess a a framework a
mental framework called Direction Over
speed
and the lesson is that
if you are going in the precise right
direction regardless of how quickly or
slowly you're always making progress
if you're not going in the right
direction very quickly you can actually
push yourself further away from the goal
that you ultimately want there's another
Insight from Chris Sparks who is a world
champion poker player and a productivity
expert and he says there can be no
growth without goals and it's a really
nice counterbalance he came out with it
just after James clear's Atomic habits
and I said I would love to get those two
guys together to talk about this
um they don't conflict they they Mash
nicely but I do think it's an important
redress
as soon as James said
you do not rise to the level of your
goals you fall to the level of your
systems as soon as he said that
I think that and the success of the book
which was phenomenal
and is in one of myself it's still like
the number one New York Times bestseller
it's phenomenal yeah it's a it's a
Powerhouse and rightly so right it's
it's one of my five books on my 100 book
list that you have to read
as soon as he said you do not rise to
the level of your goals you fall to the
level of your systems I think people
stopped thinking about goals and he made
a really great argument which was
everybody at the start line of the 100
meter race has the same goal it's to win
so it's not the person who has the best
goals it's the person who has the best
systems in preparation and that's true
as you dig in a little deeper it forgets
about Direction Over speed
and this is what there can be no growth
without goals that Chris meant which is
that it is just
personal goal mental masturbation for
you to frenetically do self-improvement
not in service of a thing or not in
service of even a direction that you're
going towards and it was a really
important reframe for me and I think
that
it plays into what you're talking about
why would you take a sabbatical
if not that there was some direction
that you were going in
I think that
the discomfort of relinquishing control
over
the day-to-day work uh especially if you
enjoy even if you don't enjoy what you
do
like it buttresses your self-worth in a
lot of ways and uh
yeah taking
um taking the manuary holiday that would
be I think that would be my equivalent
of an ultra endurance event I hate
running I hate running I got invited on
a gym shark run we're out here in uh LA
and I got invited on a gym shark run
with Noah Olsen and like some other cool
people that I'd probably love to meet I
couldn't think of anything worse I don't
want to go running yeah I would rather
do an I would I would genuinely rather
prepare for an ultra race than try and
take a full month off which is exactly
why you need to do it
or you can ride this Pony until you fall
off and you're about to crack and break
you're young you're robust uh I'm sure
your capacity to handle a lot of stress
and an extreme workload is is very large
but I think there's a Breaking Point to
all of that
and I guess my point is that
you don't need to get to that point to
recognize the value of stepping back I
think if you reframe it as
as not a break but as call it whatever
you want that makes you feel better
about what it is that you're doing
um I think it's important to do that
short of now I do it whether I feel like
I need it or not it's a prophylactic
against burnout and stress dude the only
Ripple I would say before let me finish
this thought uh to the the kind of James
Clear thing that you were that you were
talking about
just to be clear like I'm not using that
month to set goals
per se I may but that's not the intent
that I'm bringing to it the intent that
I'm bringing to it is to step back look
at my life
in all
the categories
and ask myself
what the are you doing like why are
you doing this and to really deconstruct
that why and to figure out if there's
a more evolved way
of doing what I do or maybe a new
Direction altogether
I don't set five-year goals I'm not
somebody who's like I'm trying to do
this thing I'm trying to be nimble and
responsive in the moment to what is
happening and the more I am
in connection with myself
then the more trustworthy my instincts
are about that directionality and I've
learned over time to trust and rely upon
that as the barometer of not just the
the attack that I'm taking but the steps
that I'm executing on to get there and I
think that served me well and has
allowed me to Pivot and to uh
not be afraid to
experiment try new things play with the
format with the pot it's like it's
successful don't change it just keep
doing the same thing right but if I'm
doing what I'm doing in the exact same
way I was doing it
six months ago that I'm not growing
so it's an Embrace of experimentation a
healthy relationship with failure and
holding things
looser not holding on so tight it's the
tight hold that I think you probably
have right now uh that you're so
resistant to release it it's way what
you're talking about and I'm glad that
you clarified it's way bigger picture
than goals
it's way further up what's important to
you what are your values
what is the quality of the relationships
that you have
where were you six months ago or six
months ago where did you think that you
would be now
and is that lining up and if not why
what's the missing piece in your life
what's the thing
that brought you Joy as a kid that
you've pushed aside
what is the most uncomfortable
conversation
with yourself that you've been running
away from your entire life do you have
the courage to engage with that are you
willing
to do a little bit more work can you
pull back another layer on who you are
are you man enough to do that
we all have stuff we don't want to deal
with stuff we compartmentalize or we
think well I just put that one away and
I'm not going to worry about that I'm
good
true growth true expansion and
ultimately your highest expression and
the manifestation of your greatest
potential is inextricably connected to
and linked to that willingness and
courage to do that stuff that you don't
want to do this episode is brought to
you by a product I've used every single
day for over three years now and that is
ag1 it's a foundational nutrition
supplement that covers whole body Health
helps with my energy my digestion and is
a staple every single day in my
supplement regime you don't need a
handful of pills or potions one tasty
drink every single day that covers all
of your nutritional bases this is why
Andrew human and Lex Friedman and Joe
Rogan and ritual all are massive fans of
ag1 they've upgraded the recipe 52 times
over the last decade constantly
improving to make sure that they create
the number one foundational nutrition
supplement on the planet also they've
got a 90-day money-back guarantee so you
can buy it and try it for a full three
months with one pouch per month and if
you do not like ticket on day 89 they
will give you your money back that's how
confident they are that you'll love it
if you're looking for a simpler
effective investment for your health try
ag1 and get five free ag1 travel packs a
year's supply of vitamin D and that 90
day money back guarantee head to the
link in the show notes below or go to
drinkag1.com
wisdom that's drink ag1.com
wisdom thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that clip with Rich then
press here for the full episode in all
its Glory